is being a whole personality or a
lifestyle lifestyle girl is I also think
it's part personality because there are
girls that I went to school with in high
school and then oh you're pregnant two
years later out of wedlock that was not
a shock to me even though the lifestyle
they were living at the time wasn't that
but just based on their personalities I
knew that was gonna happen and I knew
there was going to be trouble in back in
19 late 70s they did a poll in America
for asking people people who are gay
yeah do you think they were born that
way they were born gay or because of
their environment 13 said they were born
that way today it's 49 okay oh wow okay
during that time when they said 13 born
that way 50 something percent said was
because of their environment so to go
back to your question about a whole most
hoes uh their environments affect them a
lot who you party with you have to pick
up whole Tendencies the environment has
a big impact upbringing has a big impact
people you befriend has a big impact and
a part of it is your own attractiveness
to that